at Google i/o 2017 we opened the door to
room a persistence library that provides
an abstraction layer over SQLite now
room has rich version 2.0 and is part of
jetpack we fix the bugs you reported and
added some of the features you asked for
let's go over rooms main components and
see what queries are supported how to
implement my gracious and how to test
your work with a database
let's say that you want to have a table
of users and you want every row of that
table to be an instance of the user
class annotate your class with that
entity define the table name if you
don't want to use the name of the class
a stable name set the mandatory primary
key and the optional column info but
only if you want to change the name of
the color otherwise the field name is
used and that's it we'll take care of
the creation of the user table for you
so that's how the entity is done but we
need a way to access the data in the
database we do that with data access
objects dolls for short or precisely
create an interface annotated with at
TAO in this interface declare all the
methods needed to work with the database
annotating them with the corresponding
SQL query room takes care of
implementing these methods for you the
supported queries are insert update
delete query and Rock query all of them
except row query are checked at compile
time which means that if you write an
invalid query you'll find this out
immediately the closet puts together the
entities and the dolls is the room
database create an abstract class that
extends the room database annotated
declare the entities and the
corresponding dolls let's take a closer
look at the queries the return type of
query and raw query can be the entire
entity but also a subset of its fields
if you're working with guava or with
optional from the java.util package you
can also use them as return types so
this means that if there are no values
to satisfy your query then your query
will return optional dot empty or
optional dot absent depending on which
optional you're working with all of
these queries are synchronous meaning
that they will be run on the same thread
you are triggering them from room
ensures you follow best practices by
throwing an error if you run queries on
the main thread so use your preferred
method of handling threads in Android
and make sure you're off the main thread
room also supports asynchronous query
when working with live data or
chav what's more the cars that return
life data or flowable are observable
queries meaning that you will get
notified every time the data in the
table or tables updates
whenever you alter your database schema
either because you've added or renamed a
column or table you need to tell the
database how to handle that change in
order to do that in your database class
you'll need to first update your
database version second implement a
migration class which defines how to
handle the migration from the old schema
to the new one and then thirdly add that
migration class as a parameter to the
database filter after triggering the
migrations validates the schema for you
to ensure that the migration was done
correctly if you don't want to handle
migrations and you don't need to
preserve your database data call fall
back to destructive migrations when
building the database to destructively
recreate the database only from a
specific version on-call fall back to
destructive migration from then provide
the number for that version
so we have our entities downs database
and migrations how do we test them to
test the dolls you'll need to implement
an android a unit test that creates an
in-memory database the in-memory
database holds the data only for as long
as the process is alive meaning that
after every test the database is
destroyed to test asynchronous queries
use an instant task executor role to
execute each task synchronously in our
apps implementation you'll end up
referencing the dowels in other classes
to unit test those classes just smoke
the down or implement the fake version
here's another tip to implement espresso
tests covering code that uses
asynchronous queries extend the counting
task executor role to count the tasks as
they start and finish finally don't
forget to test the migrations export the
database schema first and then use
another hand apestrong the migration
test helper this class allows you to
create the database in an older version
and run and validate each migration all
you need to do is check that the data
you inserted in the other version is
also present after the migration okay so
let's summarize this let's swallow plate
code compile time check queries ease of
implementing migrations
idea of testability and checks for
keeping the database worked away from
the main threat all of these qualities
of room make it easier and more pleasant
to work with databases helping you
deliver better apps
[Applause]
you